even more special this week because it's
run rich run week because of the
pandemic we didn't run it at the combine
there was no combine
and um there are a very small select
group of people
who kept pushing are you going to run we
should run
how can we run and one of them is a guy
who took this
uh this under his own wing
uh his remarkably philanthropic
wing by finding my run on youtube back
in the day and saying what's this all
about let me try and
join and we had a chat we're both from
staten island
and i felt like i've known him for quite
some time he ran against
jerry rice last year which took moving
heaven and earth to get that to happen
at the combine we raised a ton of money
thanks to his large s and that of his
friends who bet against him or with him
all in the name of saint jude that's my
setup for saying this guy
said let's do it again this year i'll
get seven of my friends you get
seven more with jerry rice to run from
the nfl legends community i said done
that's a very yada yada yada way of
saying we were able to pull it off
and joining me here is serial
entrepreneur and
somebody who has made quite the bid to
purchase
pending approval the minnesota
timberwolves he is mark laurie how are
you mark
hey rich great to be here how are your
hamstrings holding up
how are you doing from that room that
was tough
it took it's still recovered well you
were
you were very generous along with your
friends that you were able to get
together we just showed a shot of you
with ray lewis on the screen what was
that like to run with ray
you got a good story was he giving you
any sort of uh you were teamed with i'm
glad
he was on my team put it that way right
you got the chance to start working
against him
yeah you got a chance to feel like what
it's like to be an nfl player against
him
what was that like though mark did he
did he give you any words of wisdom any
any hype when you got you know he's very
competitive
and i loved it it was great i mean we
took it seriously and uh
it was a lot of fun no it's uh and and
everyone was excited to come back next
year so that's that's the key because i
think you know this only gets bigger
in future years and we raise a lot of
money for st jude and
just yeah it was a great great day great
event
dude you always tell me that before the
run like what are we gonna do next year
and what do i
what do i say to you every time you say
something to me like that what do i say
yeah let's get through this year
it's like running a 40 mark you got to
put one foot in front of the other until
you cross that finish line
you know and uh i like to just keep
talking about it then it happens
why well you have you would definitely
speak a lot into existence and
it's true right that you you were
looking for a charity to
to to support in one of the many
charities that you do support and you
found me on on youtube that's correct
right that's a fact
that's correct that's the way it worked
yeah basically looking for children's
uh charities and researching and saint
jude
was definitely the the leader in my mind
and and your video came up
and i saw you running the 40 like that
would be really fun
and uh that's how it started yeah do you
still think it's fun
mark after running it's more fun every
year rich
more fun next year and five years from
now rich this is going to be so bad
that's okay that's all right 10 years
from now richmond
by the way we're showing a shot of me
leading everybody out of the tunnel
there you are
locked up with rod woodson i mean this
is so cool that was a hell of a day man
that was so fun and yeah that was great
you know and and so uh you and your your
your cohorts raising over
1.1 million bucks for for
the chance to run with everybody um i i
just want to give you the floor and just
ask you you know uh what do you think of
when obviously you've accomplished quite
a bit
on a moment like that because it was
nuts to everybody in the room
mark when that happened no i mean it was
sort of
you know exceeded my expectations you
know i i kind of said a number in my
head that i thought we'd get to but it
happened all so fast and
a few of the entrepreneurs kind of
stepped up early with big donations and
others followed and it was just great to
see it was it was
it was amazing i mean um
and just gave me lots of ideas about
next year i know sorry i live in the
future
look man this is why you are who you are
mark lori this is why you are who you
are
um and so the fact that you know i'm i'm
preparing for an nfl draft
while trying to put this all together
with the help of louise carter and
dallas hitchcock and tracy pullman of
the nfl and nfl network combined
and you you were you were buying the
timberwolves mark how how did that come
together
well while this all yeah well yeah as
you know i mean
uh it's me and alex rodriguez and uh
we made a bid for the mets we we
finished second we didn't get it
but uh you know we think it was a
blessing in disguise because
you know we're super excited about uh
the nba
um and this opportunity came up
and it all happened really fast um we
really connected with glenn glenn's done
done an amazing job of of you know
building the team over the last 27 years
and
is looking for owners to sort of carry
on his legacy and to infuse
you know a new way of of thinking about
things and
and you know between alex and i's skill
sets
and knowledge we thought it was a good
match all around and glenn seems like a
great partner
uh we're excited to um you know
put everything we know uh into the
building organization
well i mean and and you're from my
hometown of staten island as well um
you've already uh gone to minnesota
minneapolis gotten to know the community
already yeah yeah alex and i flew out
there already we spent the entire day
there
just learning the community the team
players met with all the players
um i had a chance to talk to josh okogie
on the phone
uh love to see what he's doing to to
really help the
the city there uh along the lines of
racial equity and
and i think there's a lot we can do
there's a great platform to do good
and we're excited about that and uh
yeah and look forward to going back to
minnesota and spending real time there
and getting to know the community and
getting to know the fans
and seeing what we can do did you
introduce anthony edwards to alex
rodriguez
mark did you did you did you introduce
the two of them
so they're all aware of that
that was so funny
yeah i know mark laurie but i don't know
[Laughter]
now that's a story to tell mark that is
a story to tell
i know i was going to come in to ask one
thing of you uh
now that you're going to be hopefully
you know knock on wood everything goes
smoothly and you're in the nba and
everything's gonna work
about maybe shooting t-shirts into the
stands
uh once you do that but maybe getting
anthony edwards or
karl anthony towns to run a 40 next year
i don't know again if that's part and
parcel of the contract
sure i mean how about how about dropping
them with drones
how about that see we're gonna really
infuse some
some new ways to think about using tech
in the stadium and it's got some really
cool ideas um which may include drones
and dropping t-shirts okay
we could do that and then like i said um
what do you what are you go what are you
already thinking about for next year
because again we're
we're hitting the finish line we're
trying to raise as much money at nfl.com
run rich run to try and match what you
and your your uh
your fellow donors were able to do what
do you got for next year what are you
thinking about right now
more more runners more more people i
think yeah i think i think we get i
think we get more athletes more
entrepreneurs
and uh make it a bigger event yeah i
mean we've got the right
obviously we've got the best legends in
the game but you know let's get more
and uh do it bigger and try and i mean
we're gonna hopefully double last year
yeah
right and if we can do that we'll go
double next year i love it i love the
way you're thinking mark and again
um i always appreciate you trying to
push me and push this event to go in a
certain direction
and um i can't wait to show the results
of everybody's 40-yard dash including
yours
at the co uh during the draft on
saturday at 5 eastern time on nfl
network
and i appreciate all that you've done
mark you have no idea how many lives
that you have saved
and touched well thank you thank you
rich but really i mean you started this
and
you've been pushing it for a long time
and it's finally you know
starting to take off which you know is a
testament to you and
and you know the commitment that you've
had to think you over this period of
time so
i'm just trying to help you know but you
you this is your thing well i appreciate
you using the phrase take off in regards
to the fundraising because that doesn't
really apply to my 40 but we're going to
keep working on that too mark
we'll keep working on that too thanks
for the time and thanks for your
generosity as always you take care we'll
chat soon all right take care you go
that's mark laura everybody at mark
glory on twitter
anthony this is alex alex this is
anthony
hopefully cameras were rolling on that
[Laughter]
nfl.com run retron we're currently
nearing as well
as there are two corporate partners
lowes
uh nfl network game day morning uh
presenters and zebra technologies
have chimed in and i cannot thank them
enough we are closing in right now at
with your donations and
other donations that have child that
have closed in as well
uh from some of mark's friends and um
and
nf from the nfl community the ravens
once again the bishops
uh steve and renee have donated
generously once again
um eddie debartolo in honor of jerry
rice
he and the bashadi family have both
donated a hundred thousand dollars
we're closing in on 1.5
we haven't even gotten to ohio nfl.com
run richrun
every dollar goes to save a child's life
and also as part of that make sure that
the families never see a bill for the
healthcare or the journey to saint jude
in in memphis or for lodging or for room
and board
all of that's all of that pressure is
removed so everybody can focus on the
kid getting better and there's also
the research part of saint jude that's
why it's called saint jude children's
research hospital we've heard also from
other members of the nfl community i
could not be more
pleased about it so please get involved
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here